have you guys seen mr. doctor yet
alright well if you have or have not
seen mr. doctor yet this is your spoiler
warning I'm about to ruin mr. doctor
that's dr. strange for those of you who
take everything on the internet really
literally so when we meet dr. strange in
dr. strange did super cocky I thought he
was rad he's laughing joking hitting on
Rachel McAdams we think he's great you
seized my kiosk place I want that swanky
place he's beating down the road in the
rain where you're liking this that's not
smart
Rex Rex his hands now when she's telling
him he's in the hospital bed there are
pins in his hands he's like what did
they do to me she's explaining
everything you can tell it's a doctor
hearing what's wrong with him you can
tell in his head he's like if I were
telling someone this I would be like I
would know these if their hands is over
ergo my life is over or at least very
much change and she was like no one
could have done better I was like oh
don't don't say you could have done
better cuz that's that is the worst
nothing worse than knowing that you're
screwed because someone wasn't as smart
as you anyhow now he's got the
shaky-shaky CPT he's like there's no way
for me to come back so I was like this
one dude shattered his spine he was fine
he finds that guy and the guys like yeah
it's because I'm magic in this place
Benny Tripps balls like when Tilda
Swinton touches his head and he is
flying through the cosmos Oh multiverse
really is going inside his eye and
everything dude I'm just saying if you
watch that hi nice knowing you see you
next fall it's over I know some of you
were going to do that I'm saying it's
permanent be warned because what was in
that team really that's that's my
question
odds are dr. strange you still knocked
out cold on the foot what did that
happen at the end of the movie sure he
just wakes up on the ground at the end
of the movie right there after he drank
the tea she's like ha Durbin poison not
everyone good and alleged then he
embarks on his super quest and I wanted
to tell you guys more about what I
thought was cool about the fights the
astral projection fight when he's dying
in the hospital and you got Rachel
McAdams trying to you know zap boom his
astral projection is other dudes astral
projection they're fighting and all she
sees with things like getting knocked
off with a shell with full force they're
flying through it but in our realm it
just so ever slightly gives it energy
and then it falls onto the ground just a
little bit of a disturbance every time a
pen rolls off your desk now you're kind
of wonder straight up though when Doctor
Strange got that cloak of levitation who
else thought of the carpet from Aladdin
like seriously
that cloak was a character and add
personality it had thoughts it wiped his
tears from his eyes granted he didn't
have the personality of the carpet from
Aladdin there's still a personality
personality goes a long way and in my
spoiler free review I ended up cutting
out this part where I said this movie
has an unexpectedly clever ending I
didn't want you guys to know that I
didn't want you to know that anything
was clever so I just took it as like a
you'll watch it you'll know what I mean
what is Mads Mikkelsen as much as he is
an agent of evil he's not the evil
although from his perspective he's
actually doing good there's this whole
monologue he has but dr. strange for
he's like there's this being in this
dark energy dimension opposite of ours
and he's just kind of annexes worlds
into its world and then they live
forever because time has no place there
but even then he's like I'm doing it for
good and strange is like really I mean
look at your face and it's true at what
point are you doing what Mads Mikkelsen
in this movie is doing then you look in
the mirror and you look like that you
see that staring back at you're like
yeah I'm totally fighting for the good
guys here but it's cool because strange
gets onto the battlefield at the end
it's like it's already falling all this
[ __ ] our world is going to heads going
to the dark energy world that dark world
has won we don't have link with this
mirror to save it then he gets an idea
is like I'll be back if he goes there
and he puts on a time loop and he's like
hi I've come to make a bargain and super
evil God who kind of looks like an
ethereal version of reptile for mortal
combat just blast him with the laser and
he comes back he's like hi I'm coming to
make a bargain it's like BAM kills him
again hi I've come to make a bargain
impale him hi I've come to make a
bargain things like what is this he's
like yeah this is time this is how it
works because time has no place there so
this thing really has never experienced
time he's put him in a time loop and now
he's going to keep looping and strange
says he'll break the loop if he makes a
bargain with it the bargains simple [ __ ]
off take your zealots with you never
come back
I think it's pissed this keeps killing
them strange comes back hi I'm here to
make a bargain it relives the same
moment over and over and over again
which I heard him feeling something like
that would happen at a point in this
movie because when strange finds that
book dealing with time and he starts
messing with time and you see the apple
rotting and then coming back and rotting
and coming back and they're like stop it
what are you doing are you crazy that is
forbidden do you want to stay in a loop
forever and ever that could happen I was
like I feel like it's a very on-the-nose
foreshadow
that's alright that's gonna happen but I
thought
was a super clever ending however if I
were that Super God ish dark world thing
I'd have gotten around it
seriously you literally are in a loop
forever this guy's never gonna break it
you can do some straight-up Prometheus
[ __ ] here Prometheus was tortured over
and over and over again he was in a loop
essentially and it kind of sounded like
a sucky ass thing so you just torture
strange until he dies he'll come back
you torture him again you just keep
doing that until strange is convinced to
be like him I'm gonna break this loop
goodbye then you kill him for real I
know he threatens he was like you can
experience strange is like pain and I
are old friends but he gets vaporizes
them kills him instantly now come on man
they're gonna be full evil be full evil
did he reach down dr. Strange's throat
rip his balls out have him die come back
and be like do you want to do that again
no okay
[ __ ] your bargain what anything about
chiwetel ejiofor is he's more dough and
I didn't know that I heard more dough
might be in the movie I'm Ordos a bad
guy I have zero clue I know that
turns out he's him it's just the origin
story of it and that's the ends one of
the end credits scenes as he finds the
dude from demolition man who had his
magic and He healed himself he takes his
magic back and he's like they're too
many sorcerers or oh and the sequel is
guys gonna go around killing them
strangers gonna have to stop him so it's
like Sinestro from Green Lantern done
right then it all hit me Doctor Strange
is a better version of Green Lantern
cocky-doody
brought into a bigger world that shows
him that the world he knew is just a
small cog in a very big wheel he joins
his group of people becomes a hero among
that world he has to fight a big
formless evil thing that's going to
wreck our world and then someone he
considered a friend turns bad for the
signal no this is not a knock on dr.
strange I could find a great movie
somewhere that is essentially the plot
of Batman and Robin just done better I'm
just saying it's proof positive you can
take a premise and do it better one of
the things that just stuck out of me is
it's a better way they did it in Doctor
Strange that Green Lantern totally
failed that was the big bad guy parallax
didn't really didn't say anything at
least Doctor Strange when they have
their super villain that comes in he's
this otherworldly thing that really is
more or less formless he talks to the
thing and he bargains with it he doesn't
just kind of suck it into the Sun and
have that be that but it was funny the
parallels between the two and the other
post-credit scenes now there's two
there's like a mid-credits scene in a
post-credits scene because one is just
not enough for the Marvel Empire it's
dark too strange talking
for I guess Thor has brought Loki to New
York and strange is like okay if I help
you find Odin will you take your brother
out of here he's like sure he's there
all right let me help you find him two
things I noticed one strange has his
yellow gloves that he has on a comic
book now so I guess he's full strange
and two I was like is it setting up for
Thor Ragnarok or it's just kind of
unwrite ileft
Thor the dark world that Thor the dark
world left off like where's Odin you
think all right is Ragnarok going to
pick up where that left off in which
case is strange gonna set him on the
path for Thor Ragnarok or is Thor
Ragnarok gonna pick up where Odin's
there and they're like oh hey I'm so
glad Doctor Strange helped me find you
in which case is just rewriting it
because different directors different
minds and things shift around and they
just have to unright some things
sometimes don't know point is Doctor
Strange is pretty sweet I'm just saying
it's a cool movie it's a fun movie it's
a mind-bending movie and I thought the
end with the whole time loop thing I
thought that was rad and it's just at
this point man Marvel is there like
Pixar there Pixar with no real cars -
you could argue that maybe a couple of
them for cars one there's no real cars -
yeah and so now it's up to you what do
you guys think of Doctor Strange where
does it rank among the Marvel Cinematic
Universe you don't have to list them all
just say it's between this one or this
one if you want if you want to list them
all hey go nuts comments section is
there for you so whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]